8 news now breaking news alert
and thanks for staying with us here at 6
30. i'm denise valdez and i'm john
langley we start with breaking news in
henderson police say a ten-year-old boy
has been shot and killed his 14 year old
brother allegedly pulled the trigger
this happened this morning in a
neighborhood not too far from gibson and
horizon ridge parkway sasha loftis joins
us now live with the latest
denise and john since this did happen
this morning the police presence the
crime scene is no longer here in this
neighborhood but we're told this
shooting did happen here on this street
that ten-year-old boy shot and killed
according to police by his 14-year-old
brother now again this happened this
morning around 9 00 a.m no word on what
led up to this situation but we're told
that 14 year old was taken into police
custody and booked into the clark county
juvenile hall on one count of
involuntary manslaughter we did speak
with a woman earlier who lives around
the corner and is also a parent herself
she shared just how devastating this
whole situation is
that's extremely devastating i can't
even imagine what they're going through
or
what like i just can't i can't because i
like if that ever happened to me i don't
know what i would do
now again police say a ten-year-old boy
shot and killed by his 14-year-old
brother who is now facing an involuntary
manslaughter charge connected to this
case we have been speaking with
neighbors all evening and all of them
just sharing that same sentiment of
shock and sadness that this happened
this of course is a developing situation
so stay with eight news now for the very
latest through the evening reporting
live tonight sasha loftis live local now